The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Okay, so this is I
could say delta function day.
Break from linear
algebra mostly.
So we're looking on another
type of right-hand side.
Before in the
differential equation
and in the difference equation.
So the right-hand sides up
to now, the one we looked at
was a uniform constant load
second derivative equal one.
Now a point load.
Well in a way, we're now solving
a whole bunch of problems
because the point load can
be in different places.
So instead of solving
one problem with one
on the right-hand side, we're
solving with a delta function.
Now a delta function is, you
probably have seen and heard
the words and seen the symbol,
but maybe not done much
with a delta function.
It takes a little practice
but it's really worth it.
It's a great model of maybe what
can't quite happen physically,
to have a load acting exactly
at a point and nowhere else.
So the delta function
is, I drew it's picture,
the delta function is zero, this
is delta of x is zero except
at that one point,
the origin, x=0,
and then all along
back to zero again.
So nothing's happening, no
load except at that one point.
And let me just, so
there's no hesitation
in when I change from x to x-a,
what does that do to a graph?
If I have a function of x and
I instead shift the function
to f(x-a), I shift x to
x-a, well in this case,
and in all cases, it will
just shift the graph.
So if I drew a picture
of delta, of x-a,
the load now would
happen when this is zero,
because it's delta at
zero is the impulse,
and now this is zero at x=a.
In other words, the load
moved to the point a.
So there is the shifting
load, but the load
could fall anywhere
between zero and one.
So delta of x, the load
actually falls at zero.
Well we don't quite want
that load at the boundary.
So let's think of the point
a, the load point as somewhere
between zero and one.
Can I just take a little
time to recall the main fact
about delta functions?
When I say recall, it could
very well be new to you.
So that's what the
delta function--
that's my best graph
of the delta function.
But of course I'm, in
using the word function,
I'm kind of breaking the rules
because no function-- I mean
the function is, functions
can be zero there,
but they're not
supposed to be infinite at
a single point in between,
but this one is.
Let me go back to delta of
x to match these figures.
Of course, they would also
just shift along by a.
Maybe no harm in that.
Sorry, I'll stay there and
now I want to integrate.
And that's when a delta
function comes into its own.
Its value of infinity is
a little bit uncertain.
What does that mean?
But when we integrate
it, what's the key fact
about delta function?
That the integral of
a delta function from,
let's say, let's
integrate the whole thing,
we can safely start
way at the far left
and go away to the far
right because it's zero
all the time there except
at one point, and you know.
So what's the area
under that spike?
It is one.
That's right.
So that's the fact, the
sort of central fact
about a delta function.
That the area is one.
Oh well, let me, while
I'm really writing down
the central fact, let me write
it more specifically, more
generally.
Suppose I integrate, and this
is delta functions now really
showing up, if I integrate a
delta function against some,
times some nice function.
Now have you ever
thought about that?
What would be the answer if I
integrate the delta function
against some nice function?
So I'm still getting zero from
this term all the way along
until I hit the spike and
then after it goes back
to zero again.
So, whatever, it's gotta
be at the spike, at x=0,
because I put the spike
here at zero, the impulse.
So what do you think's
the answer for that one?
Yeah, It's the function.
So, yes, tell me again
and I'll write it down. g,
it's a value of this function g.
We don't care what it is to the
left and to the right at zero
because it's really at zero
that this thing turns on
and its value at
that point is just--
gives us the amplitude of
the impulse, which is g(0).
And of course if g is the
constant function one,
I'm back to that formula.
But this is maybe the
thing to watch for.
Actually there's a lot built
into that little thing.
We'll come back to that.
So that's delta
functions integrated
and now here are some pictures.
These are the good pictures.
So here's one integral
of the delta function.
It's a step function.
And the step of course
will occur at the point
a if the integral of the
delta function at a point a
will be the step function.
Where the action happens.
The jump happens, I could
call it a jump function.
At that point a.
Because, just for
the reason we said.
That if we integrate,
the integral is zero.
And then as soon as our
integral passes this point,
so this is integral of the,
this is-- I integrated.
I integrate to get
to this picture.
I start with that delta function
and I integrate and it suddenly
jumps to one as soon
as the integral goes
past the spike, the impulse.
So a step function.
Very handy function,
step function.
Sometimes called a
Heaviside function
named after the guy who--
the electrical engineer
I think who first sort of work
out the rules for using these.
Let's integrate one more time
because we have second order
equations, second derivatives,
so we better integrate twice
to see what sort
of answer we get.
Now integrate the step function.
So again, the integral is
zero all the way to the left,
so I'm still getting zero,
but now beyond this point
I'm integrating one.
And the integral of one is x.
So now that I would
call a ramp function.
That's a nice short word
for this valuable function.
A ramp function is the function
that's zero and then x.
So tell me about
that ramp function.
Just think about it.
What happens to its
derivative at the point a?
As I run along and I
hit this key point,
what happens to the
derivative of the ramp?
What does the derivative do?
Focus on that ramp now.
What does the derivative
do at that point?
It jumps.
The derivative jumps.
The slope is the derivative,
the slope jumps from zero
and here the slope is one.
And of course that's
what that's telling us.
Here's the picture
of the derivative.
What does the second
derivative do?
Well, since I
integrated twice I guess
going back two
steps I'll find out
what the second derivative is.
So the first derivative
takes a jump.
The second derivative is
the derivative of that jump,
so it's got the impulse.
So the second derivative,
it's a straight line here,
second derivative
a straight line.
This is straight line
here, second derivative
of a straight line
is a straight line.
But at that point the
first derivative jumps,
the second derivative
has that delta function.
In other words,
that's that stuff.
If I keep integrating -- and
I don't need higher integrals
in today's lecture -- another
integral would be what?
If I integrate this
function, then it's
running along the zero.
What's the integral of this?
Doesn't quite turn that steeply.
What's that curve there?
If I've integrated the ramp.
Here is the integral.
First, the next step up, the
integral of the ramp would be?
It'll be x squared, yeah,
it'll be a parabola.
x squared over two,
the integral of that.
And now what do I get
when I integrate this one?
I get something very important.
Not important today, but
important in a few weeks.
And very useful in computing.
These have turned out to
be just the right thing.
So again, I'm integrating that.
Everybody can tell
me, what is that?
What's that curve now?
It's the next
integral of course.
The area under that will
be x cubed over six.
So now that is a function.
Yeah, it's worth maybe
just for practice.
What's the deal
with that function?
That's pretty smooth function.
Because it certainly passes--
right, it meets at that point.
The first derivative
meets at that point.
The second derivative
The third derivative does what?
Of this line.
The third derivative, take
three steps back down the line
and you see that the
third derivative jumps.
Right?
The third derivative of that
is the third derivative,
would be, shall I-- for C,
for cubic spline or something,
the third derivative
will be zero there.
And the third derivative
of that is exactly
like back to that, back to
that, back to one is one.
So the third derivative. so
the cubic spline's so smooth
your eye doesn't see that.
They're very useful for
drawing many, many purposes.
CAD programs would use
such things constantly
because they're convenient,
they have nice pieces
that you can fit together
and they fit together
very smoothly.
But they really are
two separate functions.
So that's up to cubic spline.
But our focus is--
These would solve, what
equations would those solve?
Well, that takes how many
derivatives to get to a delta?
So what would be the equation?
What would be the
right-hand side?
Let me take the
fourth derivative.
I'll just ask the
question that way.
What would be the
fourth derivative
of that cubic spline?
A delta, right?
Four steps back.
So what is, physically,
what are we seeing here?
Do you recognize what
kind-- If I ask now
people in mechanics,
When will we
meet a fourth order equation?
Fourth derivative equals a load.
Anybody know the
physical situation
where fourth derivative?
Beams, yeah.
It's the equation for a beam.
A beam has-- The
bending of a beam.
So it's a beam.
This eraser isn't too
very much like a beam,
but anyway I put the chalk
on it, well nothing happened.
Sit on it, whatever.
It'll bend and that bending will
be given by a beam equation.
So later we'll meet
the beam equation.
So most equations of physics,
mechanics, biology, everything
are second order, Newton's
Laws often the reason.
But we get up to
fourth order sometimes.
And very seldom get higher.
Hopefully.
Beams or plates, that
table would be a plate
and it would have a
fourth order equation.
Let's start solving
this problem.
What's the solution,
what's the general solution
to that equation?
Minus the second derivative,
so notice the minus
that I like, and the load
has now moved to the point a.
So the solution u(x), let's
write down all solutions.
Tell me one solution, first.
One particular solution.
What is one function
for which minus
the second derivative
would be the delta?
That's what we've
got over there.
So just bring that
blackboard over here.
Change its sign
because that minus,
and what are you
going to tell me?
Minus a ramp.
And the ramp, of course,
will ramp up at the point
a so that it's the second
derivative of that,
the second derivative
of R will be delta.
The minus is correct and
the point is correct.
Now does that solve our problem?
No.
The ramp is going upwards.
It's not zero.
What am I forgetting?
What do I not yet have?
There's more to this solution.
Just as there was
for a uniform load.
What was the more?
Constant and-- and I want
two homogeneous solutions,
null solutions, two solutions
with second derivative equal
zero.
One of them is C and
the other one is Dx.
That's the whole solution.
So what I want to-- I
mean we need that C+Dx.
We've got two
boundary conditions
to satisfy, just as before.
So I need two constants,
that'll do it perfectly
and I'll get an exact answer.
And so this is a ramp.
Oh yeah.
Before I go further, how
would I think about this?
This is a ramp that
turns which way?
Down.
Right?
With that minus sign, that ramp
turns down at the point x=a.
Right?
It's derivative goes
from zero to minus one.
The slope of this guy drops by
one because of the minus sign.
Sorry the slope of the ramp
function, of minus the ramp.
It goes at zero, drops by one.
And what this is going
to do is take that ramp
and adjust it to go
through the fixed ends.
Oh, let's just do it.
Let's just do it.
What are C and D?
My point a-- let
me draw a graph,
that's always the best thing.
Always draw a graph
of these solutions.
So let me put in the point a.
So I'm drawing now a picture of
the solution from zero to one.
I'll graph it.
What do I have here?
Shall we just plug in
the boundary conditions
and find C and D?
That's the direct way.
What is C?
C I'm going to plug in.
Hopefully I might find it
from just the first boundary
condition.
If I'm starting from zero,
well this guy certainly
starts at zero, right?
The ramp hasn't done
anything until it gets to a.
And this guy is certainly zero.
So what is C?
Gone, right.
Now what is D?
Well alright, what's D?
Let's see.
Let me draw the-- So there's
a Dx, and D won't be zero.
I want that thing to
be zero at point one.
So I want to determine
D. Let me determine D.
So what is minus
the ramp at x=1?
I'm plugging in x=1.
Is that right?
I'm going straight forward here.
Plugging in x=1 into
this boundary condition,
ready for this guy.
What's the ramp?
So it's minus and
the ramp is, well
if the ramp is shifted over
then that's shifted over.
So at x=1, what's the ramp?
How high has that ramp gone?
1-a.
Right?
The ramp is x-a.
At the point x=1 it will be 1-a.
So I think I get one,
-(1-a) out of that.
Minus the ramp
plus D times what?
One, I'm plugging in x=1.
And that's supposed to equal?
Zero, good.
So I'm doing this sort of the
systematic way of writing down
the general solution.
Discovering that D,
what do I discover D is?
Put it on the other side.
D is 1-a.
And of course, don't forget
that it's multiplying the x.
Let me just draw the picture.
Here's how I think about it.
The solution is, away from x=a,
what does the solution look
like?
To the left of x=a what's
my graph going to be?
It's going to be?
A straight line, right?
To the left of here
there is no load.
The equation is second
derivative equals zero.
The solution to that
is a straight line.
In other words, until I get to
a, this thing hasn't started.
It's only this straight line.
The solution does
something like that.
It's a straight line.
And I guess, actually,
that's what it is.
Because the C isn't here and
that's all we've got left.
So that's that straight line.
What is it for the second half?
Tell me what the solution
looks like in the second half.
In between a and one.
It's going downhill.
Why?
Because it gotta
get back to zero.
And how's it going downhill?
It has to be linear.
In this region,
has to be linear.
Why?
How do I know it's linear here?
Because one way is to say
the equation in that region
is second derivative equal zero.
Second derivative equal
zero, straight line.
This is my solution.
It's (1-a)x here and it's
whatever it is to get back
to zero.
What will it take
to get back to zero?
Let's see.
Well we could plug in, we've
got one expression here.
Or I could just look at that.
I could say, okay what's the
equation for the straight line
that's at this point, what
is the, yeah, it's (1-a)x.
I want it to be linear.
I want it to get to zero.
Let's see.
If I want that, it would
be great to have 1-x times
something.
I have to figure out what.
Because with the 1-x at
x=1, that'll drop off.
That's linear.
What number, what's
the key here?
That slope, I want to
match them up there.
And that's the point x=a.
This is supposed to
match that at x=a.
Do you have an idea
for what I should take?
What do I put right there? a.
Look at the symmetry in those
two sides. (1-a)x going up.
(1-x)a going down.
At x=a it hits
that point, right.
So we've solved it.
We could think about
this different ways.
I could have got
that 1-x, let's see,
I could have got it
from the formula.
In a way I like to get it from
the picture, I see it, sort of,
I see the point.
What happened at that point?
What are the jump conditions?
This is another
way to ask, to see
how the delta function works.
What are they jump conditions?
I want to know, when I
ask about jump conditions,
I want to know what are
the conditions on u(x),
the displacement?
What are the conditions
on the slope, u'(x)?
That'll be the strain when
we're speaking about elasticity.
Just for u(x),
what's the statement
about u(x) from the
left and from the right
at that critical point,
the point of the load.
From the left and from
the right u(x) is?
The same. u(x) matches
up. u(x) from the left
is that height. u(x)
from the right is that.
I want to write down
those jump conditions.
Because that's another
way to see this. u(x),
u(a) from the left
should equal u--
do you want me to
say u is continuous?
I'll just say it in
words. u(x) is continuous,
that just means it
doesn't jump, at x=a.
So that's, you could say
that's a non-jump condition.
The function itself
doesn't jump.
Why not?
Because we're talking about
some elastic bar on which
we put a point load.
The thing isn't going to break.
The displacement is
going to be continuous.
But what's the condition
on u'(x), the derivative,
the slope?
So that's the function
and now tell me
what's the deal on the slope?
What's the comparison
between the-- I
have a slope of whatever
it is going along here
and I have a slope
of-- a new slope.
So u'(x), the
slope jumps, right?
And how much does it jump?
Minus one.
It drops by one.
The slope, because of my minus.
So this tells me that--
Yeah, let me write that down.
u'(x) drops by one.
This is another way to say
what the equation is asking.
The equation is looking for
two pieces of straight lines
that meet at a but their
slope drops by one.
By the way, what
were the slopes?
It's good to graph
the slopes, too.
Let me graph the slopes.
The slope u', the
derivative du/dx.
What's the slope here?
Slope is 1-a at
this point, right?
The derivative is
1-a along here.
So slope is 1-a.
And now at x=a the slope
changes to this one.
And what's the slope
of that second part?
Minus a.
Look.
It did it right.
Minus a is the slope along here.
Do you see 1-a?
It dropped by one.
The one disappeared to
leave a slope of minus a.
I guess if I just imagine a bar.
I'm fixing it at both ends.
There's a bar.
I'm just thinking
for people who like
to see a physical picture
of what's happening,
that's what this is, we'll do
it properly very, very soon.
I've got a bar.
It's a very light bar.
Its weight is not
a problem here.
But it's got a
load at the point.
So I'll measure x
going downwards.
And at the point x=a I'm
hanging a heavy load.
A load.
How do I draw a load?
Maybe I'll make a big
weight or something.
What's going to happen to
this dumb bar when I do that?
Just tell me physically.
What's going to happen?
What's going to
happen above the load?
It's going to stretch,
right, tension.
The load is going to
pull the bar down,
it's going to stretch this part.
And because nothing
special is happening,
it's going to
stretch it linearly.
And then what's going to
happen below the load?
Compression.
So the slope will go negative.
And nothing special happened
so the slope will be negative
but it'll be constant.
The slope will drop
from this to this.
The displacement, that point
will go down a little bit.
That little bit it goes down
is actually the height of this,
because that's the displacement.
It'll go down a little bit.
It'll stretch above,
it'll compress below,
and we see that in that
picture of the displacement.
The displacement's all down.
Right?
Displacement-- You know, nature
is still going to-- All the bar
is going to move down.
That's why this function
doesn't, this function,
the displacement
function is positive.
It goes all down.
But the slope function
is positive here,
so tension is positive
slope, stretch.
And compression is negative.
Well all that to
solve this equation.
Maybe while we're on a roll,
let's solve the free-fixed guy.
So this is our-- might
as well be systematic.
This is the fixed-fixed problem.
Let me below it solve
the free-fixed problem.
So it'll be minus u'',
that's the second derivative,
equals delta at x-a.
Same setup.
But now the top end is,
so it's free at the top.
What does that mean?
Slope is zero at the top but
it's still fixed at the bottom.
So this will be now free-fixed.
Let me go straight
to the picture.
Let me go straight to
the picture of u(x).
So there is x=0, there's
x=1, here's the load at a.
What's up?
And while you're
thinking about that,
let me draw a picture
to match this picture.
A bar fixed at the bottom
but not at the top.
And it's got its load
here hanging down.
But let's do it math first, and
then check with the picture.
What have we got,
two or three ways now
to try to get the answer?
The systematic way
would be to write down
this solution and plug in
the two boundary conditions.
That'd be a straightforward way.
Yeah, we could
even start by that.
So u(x) is the
particular solution,
the ramp plus any Cx+D. And just
plug in x=0 that'll be easy.
If I plug in x=0 in
the free condition,
what does that tell me?
At x=0, this corner, this ramp
hasn't started so the slope is
zero.
The slope of the
constant is zero.
What do I learn from this
boundary condition? u'(0)=0.
That C is zero.
Before I learned that
D was zero, but now
from that condition I'm
going to learn C is zero.
Do the picture for me.
What's the graph of--
this is a graph of u(x).
Remember now it
starts from zero slope
because it's free at the top.
What does the graph look
like in the first part?
It's a straight line, has to be
a straight line because there's
no force.
And what kind of a line?
It's going to be horizontal
because it starts off
horizontal.
The slope has to be zero at zero
and nothing changes until a.
So it comes along there.
Right?
Now I've started out
with the right, left,
the correct boundary condition
at zero, which was no slope.
And now what's it going
to do the other half?
From a to one.
It's going to be again, it'll
be a straight line, right?
Because there's no force there.
And what happens at--
all the action of course
is at this point a,
and what action is it?
Tell me what sort of a line.
How do I finish the picture?
What do I do?
I start here, right?
Because the bar's not falling
apart. u is continuous.
I don't get a gap suddenly.
And now what do I do from there?
Only thing I can possibly do,
because I have to end up here
and it has to be a
straight line, that's it.
That's what the picture
will have to look like.
What does that correspond to
in the picture for the bar?
Well what happens with this bar?
Above the weight, what
happens to this top part
of the bar in that picture?
And what happens to the
lower part of the bar?
So this was at the point x=a,
this is x=0, this is x=1.
What happens above the
bar, above the weight?
It just-- A rigid
motion, just goes down.
Because what happens
below the weight?
The same compression or
compression still happening.
This is still squeezed.
Shall I try to draw it?
So this is after the weight.
This got squeezed but this
part did not get squeezed.
And that's what
we're seeing here.
A fixed displacement.
So this means,
that picture means
that all the pieces
of the bar here
got moved down by the same
amount, whatever this,
we don't know that number yet.
And then below it
they got compressed.
Well we're almost there but we
don't yet have that solution.
Come back to this picture.
u(x) is continuous, got it.
And what's the real
condition that's
going to determine where
we are, what those heights
are, the numbers in there.
It's gotta look like
that, but we get more than
that, we gotta know what are
the actual, what is that height.
What is this?
What's the slope?
Here the slope is zero.
Here the slope is what?
What's the slope
in the second part?
That's the key.
And you know what it
has to be because what
happens to the slope?
If I have the second
derivative as a delta function
with that minus sign,
the slope drops by one.
And the slope here is zero, so
the slope here is minus one.
And now it has to get through
there, so what is the function?
What's the function that
has a slope of minus one
and comes down to zero?
It's gotta have a minus
x in it and what's
the constant to make
it come out right?
What do I write
now here for u(x)?
1-x.
That has a slope of minus one,
the derivative is minus one,
at x=1 it comes to
zero, that's it.
And what do I write,
what's u(x) up here?
And therefore, right there?
What's the displacement
there, of all this bit that
moves down, how much
does it move down?
1-a.
Why 1-a?
That's the right answer.
1-a.
Why's that?
Because it had to
match up at x=a.
At x=a, this and that match up.
At x=a, that slope, that
function and that function
match up.
So the slope picture is
zero and-- Oh, I'm sorry,
can't draw it because I'm
at the bottom of the board.
The slope picture, maybe
I can draw it here,
the slope picture
is zero along here
and then it drops by one to 1-a.
So that's a picture of u'.
Zero and minus one.
This is the thing to look at.
That's hard work, when
you're seeing delta functions
the first time.
But of course the functions
did not get complicated.
We kept a clean example.
And which we matched up with a
figure and we've got the answer
and we've got a couple
of ways to do it.
One is this standard,
systematic, plug-in boundary
condition way.
The other way is this.
u(x) does something here,
then the slope has
to drop by one.
And that's the key to everything
with a boundary condition.
So in a way, we have a piece
to the left and a piece
to the right.
Two constants here,
two constants here,
and somewhere there are
four conditions that
settle those four constants.
You know, we could have
a straight line here,
that's two and two.
But what are the
four conditions that
settle those four constants?
Well we have a boundary
condition here, that's one.
Boundary condition here is two.
We need two more
conditions to settle
the two pairs of constants,
and there they are.
Two conditions at the
jump, at the discontinuity.
Now I've got to do
the discrete case.
Are you up for
the discrete case?
The case where we're doing--
We have a difference equation,
so we're doing Ku equal
a column of the identity.
Column of I. Let me
take a specific column.
Say [0, 1, 0, 0, 0].
Let's suppose we have five--
I'm going to draw a picture now.
We have five, because
I made it five by five.
One, two, three, four, five,
here is zero and here is six.
So h is 1/(5+1), 1/6,
that's the delta x.
And my equation says-- So
what does my equation say?
Remember what K is. u is then
u_1, u_2, u_3, u_4, and u_5,
the unknowns.
K is our old friend with twos
and minus ones and minus ones.
I'm going to find the solution.
And this'll be the solution
that has a load at this point.
This is like my point a, right?
Here in the continuous
case, a could run anywhere
between zero and one.
In the discrete case, I've
got five possible load points
and I've picked the second one.
Five columns of the
identity matrix, five
places to put that
one, I put it there.
Now can I draw the picture here?
Which should we do first?
Should we do free-fixed?
Because that came out even
easier than fixed-fixed.
Notice the solution
here had two parts.
This is the way I would
write that answer.
Because you could
draw a picture,
but if you want to write the
formula, what would I do?
I would break it
into two pieces.
1-a up to the point
a because that's
what it was running along here.
And then down here it
was 1-x, x &gt;=a.
That's important to mention.
You have to have some guidance
on how to write the answer.
And when the answer
has two parts,
this is a good way to
write it, in two parts.
It's a little too--
you're compressing
it too much to write, to
use that ramp function.
Better to split it apart
into before a and after a.
What's going to
happen over here?
Oh yeah, can we take a
shot at this problem?
And let me mention again,
in the review that'll
be in here this afternoon and
every Wednesday afternoon I'll
just be ready for questions.
Please bring questions.
They can be questions
on the homework.
Even better if they're
questions on other problems,
questions on the lecture.
Questions are essential to
make that help session helpful.
What do you think's
cooking here?
At a typical-- Somewhere
in the middle here,
I'm going to draw the u's.
Shall I just draw them?
And now what's my condition?
I gotta put the
boundary conditions on.
Oh, I have put the
boundary conditions on it.
By putting that two
there, I'm up to here.
Okay, let's do that one.
When I chose K and
put a two in there
I was picking the fixed-fixed
boundary condition.
So can I just say it's
going to be beautiful.
The solution over there is
going to look like this.
The solution over here is
going to be up, up, up.
It's going to be a straight
line but only points in a line
and it'll be straight line down.
That value, that
value, that value.
Those will be u_1,
u_2, u_3, u_4, and u_5.
And once more, this is
going to drop by one again.
Actually I didn't have
to redraw the picture.
It falls right on.
In case x is 2/6 so that
it fits that picture,
I'm claiming we have another
extremely lucky case.
If we can use the
word lucky for math.
I'm claiming that the
way the-- You remember
for the uniform load
with a one, when
we had second derivative
equal one, the solution
was a perfect parabola
and the discrete solution,
the difference equation
was right on the parabola
for this fixed-fixed case.
It's going to happen again.
It won't always happen.
Those are the only two important
right-hand sides I know.
They're the two most important
right-hand sides and those
are the two lucky ones.
If we have a constant that
lies right on a parabola,
if we have a delta function,
it lies right on a ramp.
And there it is.
So that's what the
solution looks like.
Now, I have to figure out what
these numbers are, I guess.
Yes, what are those numbers?
Oh, well.
Actually, if it falls right
on, I know the numbers.
So a is 2/6.
So let me keep 2/6.
That's that value.
So let me say what I think u is.
So this was a picture of u.
That's u_1, 2, 3,
4, and 5 and now
I think it lies right on that.
So it's going to be (1-2/6)x
going up and (1-x)2/6 going
down.
My point is that I'll be able
to figure out what that-- this
is u, this is the u.
You're going to say, why?
Let me pause before
putting in numbers
and say why is it, how do
I know that the solution is
right on the function,
the continuous solution.
Well, can I draw
a set of pictures
just like those
guys for discrete?
Yeah, let me just draw
those for discrete here.
That shows you the magic.
So there is a-- I'm going
to draw a vector now.
I'm going to have to lift the
chalk, it won't be a function
and it'll be the delta vector.
So it'll be the
delta vector, delta
with-- So there is point one,
zero, one, two, up to six.
It'll be the delta vector.
Well if I just draw
the delta vector,
the delta vector
has a one there.
So this is the delta vector.
Do I need?
Well you can see that
the delta vector is now
going to be the
vector of all zeroes
and it's got a one at the key--
at the impulse and then zero.
So it's a discrete impulse.
That would be a better word.
Discrete impulse.
Impulse at zero.
So let's stay with
an impulse at zero.
Alright.
What's my next picture?
Again let me put in zero.
One, two, three, onwards.
Minus one, so on.
What do I want to do now?
What do I draw second?
I always look over here.
What did I draw
second over here?
The step.
Now why did I draw
a step function?
How did I get from here to here?
I integrate.
I took the integral.
So how will I get from
here to this picture?
I don't integrate, I add, sum.
So coming along from the left,
all these all along here,
this sum is all zero
because it was always zero.
So it's zero, zero, zero, zero.
And then, whoops, wait a minute.
It says it a one there?
Yeah, I think it must be.
So here it wasn't a zero, wrong.
Here it's a one.
And what is it next?
What's next to it?
One, because I'm adding
more and more zeroes
but I have that one now, okay.
A discrete step.
It's a discrete step,
zeroes and then ones.
Now comes the second.
So what am I going to call that?
A step, right?
It'll be a step
function, step vector.
If the sums of the delta
vector gave me the step vector,
how do I go the other way?
What do I do to the
step vector to get back
to the delta vector?
Differences, right?
Sums in one direction,
differences in the other.
So the differences of the step
vector are the delta vector.
The step is the
sum of the deltas
and the delta is the
differences of the step.
Now for the crucial next guy.
What's it going to be?
I add.
Wait a minute.
What's up?
I'm looking for that picture.
Do I get it?
Yeah, I hope so.
Oh, look, we ran out of time.
I don't have to do
this, but I will.
So as I add I get zeroes
and then it's one,
and then I add on one more one.
Look.
You see what's happening.
I run along at
zero but I'm going
to look at the book to see
whether that jump should
come here or here.
So I've got a little bit
of this to finish next time
and I'm open for any
questions this afternoon.
Okay, thanks and sorry
to keep you late.